INTRO:
Usually, one of the top financial
priorities for us average people is to get out of
debt. Whether that be student loans, car loans,
or a mortgage, we want to pay them off as soon
as possible to minimize the interest we pay.
If we had the money, most of us would avoid
debt altogether, but ironically, some of the
richest people in the world also have the most
debt in the world. By now, I’m sure all of you
guys have heard about Elon’s plans to takeover
twitter for $44 billion. And given that Elon’s
net worth is currently hovering at about a quarter
trillion dollars, it’s not impossible for him to
just pay cash. Yet, he’s planning on taking out
quite a bit of debt. The current plan is to take
out $13 billion in debt against Twitter, and
$12.5 billion in debt against his Tesla stake.
This means that he’s taking out a total of
$25.5 billion in debt. Now, Elon may choose
to pay more cash by the time the deal closes
in order to minimize the risk of a margin call,
but the root question still stands. Why even deal
with debt and banks and interest payments when you
don’t have to? This doesn’t just apply to large
purchases Twitter either. Many billionaires will
take out debt to buy homes, yachts, and private
jets even though these purchases are a miniscule
portion of their net worths. Elon himself had 5
mortgages totaling $61 million before he decided
to sell all his houses and move to Texas. So, why
do billionaire voluntarily take out so much debt?
MAXIMIZING RETURNS:
One of the main reasons rich individuals prefer
to take out debt instead of just paying cash
is to maximize their returns. Given that they’re
already rich, they’re well aware of how to produce
significant returns on their money. Whether
that be investing in commercial real estate,
investing in stocks, or putting it all towards
another business, these guys are experts at
consistently beating the market. Take Tesla
for example. Since they went public in 2010,
the stock has grown from $4.15 to $870 today.
This comes out to an impressive 200x in 12 years
or an annual rate of return of 54.585%. And
that’s just the returns that Tesla has produced
as a public company. Usually, the majority of the
gains are made before companies go public. So,
for it to make financial sense for Elon to
sell his Tesla stock and let’s say buy Twitter,
Twitter would have to reliably produce more than
54.585% per year. Now of course, Tesla isn’t going
to grow at this rate forever, but I think you
get the point. Twitter would have to consistently
beat the Tesla’s annual return for it to be a
worthwhile investment. And the truth is, this
is not very likely. First of all, it doesn’t seem
like Elon is even buying Twitter to make money.
It looks like he’s buying it for social
reasons and to hopefully create change.
So, while Twitter may naturally grow to $100
billion or something under Elon’s leadership,
it’s not likely that it becomes like Facebook and
reaches a trillion dollar market cap or anything.
So, from Elon’s perspective, it makes sense to
minimize the capital that he does tie up with
Twitter given that it’s just a side project. This
same principle applies to much smaller purchases
as well. For example, let’s go back to Elon’s $61
million mortgage, this took place in early 2019.
At the time Tesla was just starting to recover
from production hell and nearly going bankrupt.
Shortly after Elon took out these mortgages, Tesla
stock actually plummeted to just $36 per share in
June of 2019. Now, imagine if Elon decided to sell
$61 million worth of Tesla stock to pay for his
properties instead of taking out a mortgage. Since
this low in 2019, Tesla stock has grown nearly 23x
meaning that the $61 million that he sold to
buy his properties would now be worth $1.403
billion. Even if we assume that the properties
appreciated to $100 million, Elon would have left
$1.3 billion on the table and that’s not even
including future growth. This argument becomes
even more relevant when you’re talking about
depreciating assets like a private jet or a yacht.
Such purchases are basically guaranteed
to lose 70 to 80% of their value if you
own them for a long period of time, so it makes
no sense to pay for these purchases up front.
The only reason you would pay for them
upfront is for some sort of peace of mind,
but in terms of returns, taking out
debt is absolutely the way to go.
ILLIQUID:
Aside from trying to maximize returns, one of the
key reasons billionaires take out debt is because
they have no choice. While they may have tens
of billions or hundreds of billions on paper,
the vast majority of this is simply paper
wealth and completely illiquid. For example,
over the past week, Elon sold $8.4 billion
worth of Tesla stock to raise the cash that he
committed to put up for Twitter. This sale itself
caused Tesla stock to fall 12% in a single day.
Imagine if Elon had to sell 5 times that amount
to raise the full cash required to buy Tesla.
By the time he was done selling,
Tesla would likely be down 60 to 70%
if not more. Aside from plummeting the shares of
his own company, he would have to deal with so
much backlash from Tesla shareholders. Many Tesla
shareholders are already pissed off that Elon
sold Tesla stock to buy Twitter. To many of them,
Twitter not only seems like unfavorable exchange,
but it also seems like a unnecessary distraction.
And they haven’t been scared to hold back their
thoughts either. This one Twitter user posted “I
don’t like that you sold shares, Elon. Your money
is not the last one out. I know people who got
margin called today. Not cool.” This other user
tweeted “I'm more disappointed he used it to buy
Twitter. Genuine question, how many more years
does Twitter have?” And all of this is just for a
12% sell off. Elon would literally be burned alive
if he caused the stock to sell off 60 or 70%. And
this is the same case with other founders as well.
Bill Gates for example had to spend 25 years to
cash out his Microsoft position. At least, these
guys have the option to sell if they really want
to. Many smaller billionaires don’t have a choice
due to stock vesting. Company owners usually
don’t want high level executives or employees
to sell off a bunch of stock if the company is
going through a rough spot. These guys selling
would just cause the stock to dip even further
and leave the company off in a worse position.
So, most companies implement a policy called stock
vesting that prevents employees from selling their
stock for a set period of time. Google and Apple,
for instance, follow a 4 year vesting schedule.
So, when we see headlines like
Sundar Pichai made $281 million
last year or Tim Cook made $265 million last year,
just know that while this is technically true,
they won’t actually have access to this money for
years to come. The only money they have access to
instantly is their cash compensation which for
Sundar Pichai is quote on quote only $650,000.
So, while someone like Sundar or Tim can
comfortably afford a $20 or $30 million
mansion on paper, they don’t actually have the
cash upfront which forces them to take a mortgage.
MINIMIZING TAXES:
While maximizing returns and liquidity are
significant considerations, something that
we haven’t even talked about is taxes. Now, a lot
of people think that billionaires should be taxed
way more, but really this wouldn’t even make a
difference because these guys implement several
clever strategies to minimize taxes, one of them
being taking out debt. While they'll have to pay 3
or 5% interest on their loans, they can avoid much
more significantly more in taxes. Currently, the
highest tax bracket for long term capital gains
is 20%. And if you live in California like many
of these billionaires do, you’ll also have to deal
with state income taxes. And to make things worse,
California doesn’t discern between capital
gains and regular income, so you’ll have to
pay the full 13.3% to California. This means
that your total tax load comes out to 33.3%.
Now, I’m not looking to argue whether this is a
fair amount or not, but this strongly discourages
billionaires from selling their stock. Going
back to Elon’s $61 million mortgage, we already
calculated that Elon would’ve left $1.3 billion on
the table if he paid for these properties in cash,
but this doesn’t include taxes. If we tack on
a 33.3% tax, we’ll see that Elon would’ve had
to sell $91.5 million worth of stock to
pay for these properties in cash. Again,
given that Tesla stock has grown 23x since Elon
bought these properties, that $91.5 million
is worth $2.1 billion today meaning that Elon
would’ve straight up left $2 billion on the table.
And looking forward, if Tesla grows
another 5x within the next 10 to 20 years,
that $91.5 million purchase which was a
miniscule portion of Elon’s wealth even in 2019
would be worth $10 billion. So, when you have
exponential growth working in your favor, you want
to be as invested as possible and you definitely
don’t want to bleed any money to the IRS.
INFLATE AWAY DEBT:
While everything we’ve covered so far are great
reasons to take out debt, even if none of those
reasons applied, the rich will still take out
debt for one reason and that reason is inflation.
Over the past year, for everyday Americans
inflation has been devastating given rapidly
rising everyday expenses. But, for people who are
holding debt, it’s actually rather beneficial.
Here’s the thing, the amount of money you owe
is not going to go up because of inflation.
But, the amount of money you earn will go up. Now,
unfortunately, wages don’t always keep up with
inflation especially in times of high inflation.
And while this strategy works best if your
income scales perfectly with inflation, it’s also
applicable even if your income doesn’t quite keep
up especially over the long term. For example,
a dollar today is only worth half as much as a
dollar from 1992. Now, let’s assume that you got a
30 year fixed rate mortgage in 1992, for $200,000.
At first, maybe half of your net income goes
towards your mortgage payment. After 30 years
though, let’s say your income doubles thanks
to inflation and promotions. At this point,
the same mortgage payment only accounts for
a quarter of your net income. And that’s with
relatively conservative growth numbers. What if
your income actually grows 5 or 10x in those 30
years? That mortgage would become a miniscule
expense by the time you pay it off. And this
is especially applicable if you have a business
in a high growth area like many billionaires.
It’s not just billionaires using this strategy
either. This is one of the key strategies
governments rely on to reduce their debt load
over the long term. They just inflate it away.
Now, I would argue that governments have taken
this to an unacceptable extreme but that’s a
wholenother conversation. All you need to know is
that making a debt payment in the future should be
easier than it is right now, so rich individuals
prefer to leverage this to their advantage.
TIME TO GO IN DEBT?:
Hearing all of these advantages, it’s likely that
many of you guys are wondering if this strategy
would work for you. And, unfortunately, if you
have to ask that question, the answer is probably
no. The best course of action for the average
person is to pay off student loans, car loans,
and credit card loans as fast as possible or not
take take out these loans in the first place.
There is one area in which the average person
could leverage this strategy, but it requires
that they’re disciplined and willing to invest
regularly. Instead of taking out a 10 or 15 year
mortgage, it would be smarter to take out a 30
year mortgage, and invest the monthly savings
into the S&P 500. But, if you know that you won’t
be that disciplined at that you’ll end up spending
this money instead investing it, it’s better to
just get the shorter mortgage and pay off the
debt. And given that the average person falls
into this category, sticking to Dave Ramsey’s
advice is likely the best course of action. But
that why it makes sense for many billionaires
to take out debt instead of paying cash. If
you were a billionaire, would you still take
out debt? Comment that down below. Also, drop
a like if this video gave you a new perspective
on debt. And of course, consider checking out
our international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.